are we are we ready to begin i think
i've got
so
uh as chairman of division two of the
house finance committee
i find that due to the state of
emergency declared by the governor
as a result of the covet 19 pandemic
and in accordance with house rule 67
and the governor's emergency order
number 12
pursuant to executive order 2020-04
this public body is authorized to meet
electronically
this public meeting is pertaining to the
university system
and the community college system
please note that there is no physical
location for members of the public
to observe and listen contemporaneously
to this meeting
however in accordance with emergency
order one
i am emergency order i am confirming
that all members of the committee and
select legislative staff
have the ability to communicate
contemporaneously
during this meeting through the zoom
electronic meeting platform
and the public has access to
contemporaneously listen
if necessary participate in this meeting
by
by the zoom platform or by telephone
all necessary access information has
been made available in the house
calendar
and through the electronic calendar on
the general court
website the notice for this meeting
complies with house rules
and rsa 91a anyone who has a problem
accessing the meeting should email lba
underscore fiscal at leg
dot state dot nh dot
us in the event the public is unable to
access the meeting
the meeting will be adjourned and
rescheduled
lba staff are on the meeting assisting
us
please note that all votes that are
taken during this meeting
shall be done right by roll call let's
start the meeting by taking a roll call
attendance when each member states their
presence
please also state whether there is
anyone in the room with you
during this meeting which is required
under the right to know
law representative lynn if you could
call the role i'd appreciate it
yes thank you madam chair representative
bucco
uh thank you i'm present i'm at my home
in conway and there's no one else in the
house
thank you representative danielson is
not present
representative heath i'm here in
manchester heath and i'm here in
manchester new hampshire
and i'm home alone thank you um
i'm representative bob lynn i'm here at
my home in windham and i'm
my wife and son are in the house but i'm
alone in the room
uh representative uh murray
good morning i'm kate murray here in
newcastle my dog is with me my husband's
in the basement
thank you uh representative petry
yes uh representative petry here uh i'm
in farmington
uh my wife and dog as usual are
roaming around the halls and
representative humber
thank you okay we're going to have to
get your husband out of the basement i'm
sorry
i'm representative carama karen umberger
and i'm in my home in kearsarge
and my husband is wandering around the
house
and will be in and out thank you very
much
um i'd like to begin this morning uh
the are you interim chancellor
acting chancellor okay and interim
interim oh okay well i was going
to make that permanent uh interim
chancellor
uh for the community college system
uh susan hooward and uh i believe
that uh you sent the presentation to us
and if you would um introduce
anyone that has joined you on our zoom
call
and i'd appreciate it and we're we're
looking forward to it
and uh just so that you know
um we're going to hold our questions
because we're going to gather back at um
about 12 30 so that we can
ask the questions at that time because
we are
on a um based on yours
and uh unh's agreement you would each
have half an hour so
all right if if i could ask you to
proceed thank you very much
thank you representative umberger um as
is the case with representative murray
he's an avid woodworker um and i'm
at home in hooksett and i've brought
with me uh shannon reed who is our
legislative affairs
liaison and scott fields who is our
chief of operations
and so thank you so much for this
time i've met some of you but not all of
you
i've actually been in new hampshire
since 2010 and
i was the president of manchester
community college
for about nine and a half years and then
i thought i retired
but in new hampshire fashion i didn't
and when chancellor gatel left i was
asked to step in
and i was very honored to do that to
support
our seven colleges and my colleagues so
what i'd like to
do in our half an hour is give you an
overview
uh of the the system and
what it is we do and and and who we
serve and
and what motivates us so
having said that um
i've been asked the question recently um
well you've got
seven different missions because you
have seven
colleges and i've said no that's that is
not the case
we absolutely have seven colleges we're
at 12 different locations in the state
but we all have the same mission and i
was trying to think of
a way for people to understand how we
could have
seven independent accreditations but we
could still be
driven by one mission and i actually
thought about the common man restaurants
you know
an institution here in the state of new
hampshire
when you go to a common man restaurant
there are certain things that you can
expect and whether you are
in the southern end of the state of the
northern end of the state there's a
certain flavor
that comes through and i think that's a
good comparison
to the community colleges the thing that
makes a community college a community
college
is its location we are
tied to the people and the businesses
in a particular area that's what makes
us
who we are but in shannon i'll ask you
to bring up our slides and i'm going to
talk about a few of these
i will not go through every single one
but just to
give you a flavor about who
who we are so two things drive us
that first one is the mission that i've
been talking about
and our goal is to serve the people of
the state
in fact one of the things one of our
distinguishing characteristics
is that more than 93 percent of the
students
in our system are new hampshire
residents
um this year i think our our youngest
student
is in about 16
and our most seasoned student is in her
80s
and that i bring those numbers up just
to give you a sense
that community colleges are here to
serve people
when they need us so here you go here's
a showing of all of us
all across the state uh in fact
our goal was to have a community college
or a center within about a half an hour
of everybody
in the state so there's the
uh sort of the the location business
the other piece is affordable and then
another slide i'll show you what the
impact is
of when we have to raise our tuition and
frankly
i'm very grateful to you because of your
assistance we've been able to maintain
our tuition currently the state funds
so looking at our slide here
there are different things one can do at
a community college
one can gain a certificate an associate
degree
short training longer term training we
do customize
training with companies and
we serve our high school students we
create pathways for students to
move to gain college credit in high
school
and then move on to the community
college
or the other college of their choice in
fact our credits in our
running start program are accepted at
more than 200
colleges and universities and we
we're increasing that number because as
our high school students go forward
to a colleges that we've not yet talked
with we add them to the list we speak
with folks at different colleges across
the country
and there's a whole bunch of programming
that we do that is designed exactly for
transfer
to four-year institutions
but our big game is to be agile
so that as things come up we can respond
one of the recent examples that has come
up is with the lpn
program you know we used to be in the
lpn business
quite a while ago and then as the
hospitals
changed their priorities and they moved
to
magnet hospital status they were telling
us very clearly that there wasn't going
to be a role for lpns
so slowly but surely we went out of the
lpn business
however in the last two years the need
for lpns particularly
in nursing homes and healthcare systems
has
arisen and so now we've gone back into
that business
having started the program again at
river valley community college
but we're doing things in a different
way
where before we would have started a
brand new program
at whichever of the next college was
going to do it
now we have a different way of operating
uh the program has started at river
valley this semester
lakes region started a new cohort
of the lpn program and frankly
this is a model that we're going to
continue doing
it may be that the state no longer needs
this program sometime in the future and
instead of
creating it at every single college
we'll bring it where it needs to be and
then when the need subsides
we essentially will fold it back up and
bring it back to the host college
we are in discussions about other
examples
like that and i bring that up because it
gives you a sense
of how we are responsive
okay so i've talked about mission our
mission to be affordable
to be accessible to serve the businesses
in the communities it's all supported by
this notion
that we've been talking about for quite
a number of years 65 by 25
which i suspect you're all very familiar
with and so our goal here
based on an analysis that was done by a
a professor at georgetown university
is that for our state to flourish
economically
65 of our adult residents
by 2025 need some kind of post-secondary
training
and i put it that way because some
people need short-term certificates
some people need longer experiences
some people need associates
baccalaureate and graduates degrees
but all together we're meaning to serve
the need of our state
and here are the ways that we do it
some of which i've already mentioned and
some of which we continue to pursue
we're looking for more opportunities
with high school students frankly the
pandemic has
changed so many things for us
and as we think about the high school
students who are going to go forward
some of whom haven't been uh in a
classroom
in about a year now those folks are
still moving along they're still going
to graduate from high school
what is it that we do to support them as
they
gain the skill sets that they worked on
on their own but they're going to be
moving on
so high school students we still need to
be affordable
one of the things that has come up
is you know why is it that the community
college system
and the university system didn't work
hand in glove
on dealing with a pandemic well we did
we we certainly have spoken with one
another and so on but our needs are very
different
our students are in the community we
have some residential students at two of
our colleges
but our needs are very different in fact
if you look at what happened to
community colleges
on account of the pandemic you you get a
sense
that that the folks that we serve are
living a different life
my predecessor chancellor gatel wrote a
paper called the two new hampshires
and in it he talked about the people
of means and the people who don't have
opportunity well we have an example
right now
with a pandemic people anticipated
that what's been true for decades would
happen and that would be
that community colleges would see this
huge growth
in enrollment because our sort of the
the old saw is
when times are bad community college
enrollment is up and that makes sense
because people are trying to
um you know brush up on their skills or
achieve new skills
that is not what happened
in fact nationally community colleges
are down any place from 10 to 15
and we are in that boat we are you know
in that in that level of
a decline in our enrollment
and that's because the students that we
serve
are on the front lines of retail they
are
the lnas in nursing homes
they are the young parents who are you
know i have kids at home
one of the uh challenges for us
our frankly the 18 and 19 year olds who
are going to come to the community
college
came and they're doing well
it's the 25 plus year olds
who have had to step out because of
working overtime because of their needs
at home and so on
and again we look exactly like what's
happening
nationally to community college students
shannon let's move on a bit here
and i'll leave this for you to read at
some point
but what we do changes but not at the
core
we need to help the people who need to
retrain and in fact
a lot of the programming that we're
building right now is exactly
to help people back to work we worry
about folks in the retail industry
and in the hospitality industry those
two industries in particular have been
profoundly affected
as you know well what are the
transferable skills
i was on a call a few weeks ago
and we're talking about the needs in
health care which is as you know a huge
employment
sector in our state and one of the
employers former employers
said if i had two resumes in front of me
and one was from um an rn
who who didn't um who
basically had gone to school and was now
applying to work
and there was a second person there who
had worked in hospitality
perhaps been a bartender sight unseen
before i talked to them
i'm already thinking i want that person
who's been a bartender
and it really got me thinking about what
are the skills
that a bartender needs that are highly
transferable
to the healthcare industry bartenders
are certainly used to listening to
people's life problems
they're used to dealing with people at
different points in their life and they
have
refined their problem solving skills
that's a good illustration of many of
our students these are folks that are
working
and they have accumulated skills they
need a flexible schedule
when the cares money first came out
it it was doled out to colleges based
upon
fte which is full-time equivalent
and that didn't support us to the degree
that we needed
because two-thirds of our student body
is part-time one-third full-time
so if you're going to come up with the
full-time equivalent you kind of
mash together two or three people
because those two or three students
might each be taking
one or two classes and so it would take
three students for instance
to be the equivalent of one fte
those three students have needs every
one of our college campuses has now
opened a food bank
every one of our colleges is helping to
connect students
to all the services our state has fuel
assistance
rent assistance and so on and when the
next round of funding carissa came out
we were very grateful
that our senators really championed a
mix
so it is fte but it also is head count
so when i tell you that we serve 26 000
people within our state every year
we need people the very talented faculty
and staff that we have to serve these
individuals well
and it is a different formula much like
before i was referring to
the difference in in how covet affected
the community colleges uh versus our
residential colleges same sort of an
issue we
we have different needs based upon who
and how
and shannon has put up on the screen the
fact that we
pay very careful attention to what the
needs of the state are
in this very good alignment between the
programming
that we do and the job opportunities
that exist
shannon next slide please all right
a little bit here about how we work
with our various companies um
two examples for you one is nashua
community college
and it's worked with bae systems
the company and the college worked
together to meet a need that the company
had for micro electronics
technicians so there's a program
now at nashua that's been there for
probably a couple years
that trains people and takes people from
making
a very basic wage to a living wage
because ultimately that's what we're
aiming for
um in in one meeting i did let my former
background in connecticut show and i
said
that the mission of community colleges
is to create middle class taxpayers
and uh one of the commissioners said to
me that that's not new hampshire susan
but really staunchly creating the middle
class and giving people that opportunity
is what community colleges are about
and we do that by maintaining
affordability
you can see on this slide that shannon
is showing us
we with your help have been able to
maintain our tuition
and in fact when we first raised our
tuition
we saw a decline in enrollment we think
we are at the price point
and i will um say to you
about the the whole conversation that
we're having
about merging the two boards i think
this
is a good idea i think it's an idea that
requires investigation
but i'll tell you my fear the university
of alaska merged their community
colleges
and their university system quite a long
time ago the late 80s
and and people were very cognizant of
the community colleges
and so initially they were able
the university system was able to
offer the community college students a
lower tuition
but as time went on they couldn't do
that any longer
there were needs and and frankly uh
for those of you who may remember an old
play the man of la mancha
there's a line in it that comes to mind
for me here this is
uh whether the stone hits the pitcher
or the pitcher hits the stone it's bad
for the pitcher
the community college system is the
pitcher
and so as we go forward and as you go
forward and consider this idea
i want you to think about what it is
that we do
for those two new hampshires if i go
back to the
statistics that have come up people who
are making 150
000 or more in our state and across the
country
have been absolutely fine through this
pandemic
the people who are making less than that
have experienced
one of the points that i'm proudest of
is on your screen right now
i've talked about creating the middle
class uh one of our claims to fame
is the value of a community college
education
people in our state who've attained a
degree
have moved two or more economic
quintiles
from where their parents are as a parent
you want your children to do better than
you have
and we are like the good housekeeping or
we have like the good housekeeping seal
of approval
our students do well and in fact
our two rural colleges white mountains
and river valley
are they they actually lead the nation
in terms of what the impact
of a community college education is for
these folks
this slide here looks at graduation rate
um
one thing about graduation rate you can
see that our graduation rate is
33 and you might say well you know
what are you so excited about susan with
a graduation rate of 33 percent
but i want you to understand where that
comes from so this is a federal
requirement so a brand new
which is called a first-time freshman is
part of this
count and then for our
community colleges they look at how many
of those students graduate in three
years
what happens to our students is they
start off full-time
and then family and work
get in the way and i don't i hesitate to
say get in the way because those are
absolutely crucial pieces so that
student who started off full-time
three years from now may very well still
be with us
but he or she is not full-time
and so they are con we are considered a
failure
because they didn't graduate within the
three-year period
if you look at what's happening in
community colleges
you can see that we are outpacing
our sister institutions and we've done
that because of work we've done
with national entities to raise the
graduation rate
to look for ways to sustain people
we've grown by 10 percentage points in
five years
we want to grow at least that over the
next five years
um shannon is bringing us through
um a list of all of the employers that
we have done work with
several more pages here um i hope that
i've given you
background about who we are and the work
that we do
i see eversource here i had mentioned i
wanted to give you two examples and i
only gave you one with bae
and nashua eversource has worked with
manchester community college
to create a line worker program
those folks are with us for less than a
year
and their average starting salary is
about 75
000 there's still more opportunity there
there's more opportunity to work with
all of our
partners and i i'm pleased to tell you
that we continue to do that work
despite the pandemic so i think i've
left maybe just a couple of minutes
scott will you take us through the
absolutely thank you chancellor hewitt
good morning everybody my name is scott
fields i'm the chief operating officer
of the community college system
i am at home in intervale new hampshire
my family is on the first floor not the
basement so i think i'm doing
okay i just wanted to run through
the fy 22-23 efficiency budget you know
this request
is developed with a focus on the
continual improvement of our student
outcomes
mentioned earlier in this presentation
and as chancellor hewitt just said
this outlook has allowed ccsnh to become
a leading community college system in
all of new england in terms of these
graduation rates and economic mobility
with this in mind the requested increase
over the biennium will allow us to
maintain these
student first focus and to continue to
be a key component in the state's
economic engine and recovery during this
challenging time
the state's support of ccsnh's mission
is a crucial component of our funding
matrix as a percentage of our tuition
and fees revenue compared to state
appropriation has shifted
quite significantly over the last five
years
just to give you in terms of the
national perspective the average
reliance on tuition and fee revenue at a
community college is roughly 33
ccsnh is approximately 17
higher than that or nearly 50 so your
support
over the last few years has provided us
the ability to continue the success that
we've had
and to just look at the numbers within
our
budget request the increase from fy21 to
fy22
is 5.3 million dollars the vast majority
of that
is predicated from our three collective
bargaining agreements
and mandated increases for things
similar to the
new hampshire state retirement system uh
mandates that come out each and every
year
so from fy21 to fy 22 a prime example
of this is the retirement system
increase is going to cost the
community college system nearly 1.5
million dollars from fy21 to fy22
that dollar amount is nearly 65 percent
of our overall benefits increase in that
one year
so essentially your continued support
will help us to maintain the systems
and our positive outlooks that we have
right now
and continue to go forward as chancellor
hewitt just said we're looking to
continue to grow
these outcomes over the next few years
um sorry just getting my place here
so over the next oh thank you shannon so
what happens is in the fy 22 budget we
are state
we're flat funded with the state dollars
uh that will allow us to continue where
we were at right now
while trying to find a way of absorbing
the 5.3 million dollar
contractual increases that we need to
have in order to maintain
the successful outcomes that we're
continuing to grow
with the fy 23 budget in question
being rolled into one bucket there's
significant work that needs to happen
over the
next few years or in the next year or
two that will help us understand
exactly what our individual budget will
look like at that
one last thing just to go ahead
oh sorry uh
but one thing to just keep in mind is
you know ccna ccsnh excuse me prides
itself
on being nimble and entrepreneurial over
the last few years
we have worked diligently as
all other state agencies have to reduce
costs and maintain costs where necessary
our operating costs have dropped by
nearly eight percent from
fy 18 through fy20 we take being
fiduciary responsible actions
each and every year in each and every
budget in order to
control our costs to show good
stewardship of the money that the state
provides to the system
this is something that we will keep
going scott i just wanted to
show these as people are listening uh so
you know we definitely pride ourselves
in this fashion and being able to be
good stewards of the funds that you
provide to us
and look forward to continue to do that
again the request that we're
seeking will allow us to maintain that
same level of service
across the board to our students so it's
just
it's it's important that we are able to
continue to move that needle especially
when it comes to 65 by 25.
again we are a key component and
economic driver of the state's recovery
especially in times like this when
there's so many structurally unemployed
folks that do need to be
retold as chancellor hewitt mentioned
earlier
uh shannon would you comment on these
slides and representative on the
burger i know we're slightly over but if
we could have one more minute please
no problem i tacked these slides on as
an appendix these come from
brian gottlob an economist with the
labor market information bureau
and it looks really at what are those
professions that
are um they're in demand right now and
then projected forward to be in demand
and so many of them fall at the
associate degree or
certificate level which is the level of
education that we
um kind of specialize in so this is just
some detail that
um that rolls up to the larger theme
that the community colleges really exist
to meet these
workforce needs in ways that match
the demographics of our community and
the demands within
within each of our communities all
across the state and and so i guess i i
wanted
you to see this because this isn't just
us saying this
this is um you know very very well
regarded
economists saying this who have looked
at this data and this is what this is
what they do for
for a living and it's really folds into
everything that we've been saying about
our role here in the state of new
hampshire
thank you shannon we'll be happy to
answer questions this afternoon we look
forward to the conversation
as part of the package that we've sent
you there's also
a link to a document that gives you
some information about how mergers have
played out in other states
and because as this goes forward
i always say to the folks that work with
me let's make new mistakes
so we need to keep history in mind we
need to look at
what others have done and then build on
that and
we're confident that you can help this
state and our residents
in our community college system and our
our partners at the university system to
do the same
i really enjoyed working with my
colleague catherine provencher
the two of us see this as an and not as
an or
we are not in competition we are in
collaboration with one
another and i thank you so much for the
opportunity to talk with you about our
system
thank you very much as you know
i love the community college system and
i love
the university system so thank you very
much you've done a uh
a great job in uh letting us know
where you come from and what you do so
uh
mickey if you could bring um
uh catherine provencher up to
talk i'd appreciate it
all right they uh kathy and tom cronin
are
pulled in now as panelists and and i'll
leave the
ccsnh folks as panelists now just in
case some of the discussion as we move
forward this morning
applies okay thank you very much
welcome interim chancellor is that the
right term
no no no it's actually
so so good morning and um
thank you representative umberger and
members of division two it's uh
it's great to see you uh even though
it's
in this uh strange zoom land so
uh for the record my name's catherine
provencher
i am serving as the chief administrative
officer
of the university system with um
chancellor leach
leaving his post as of january 1st i'm
also
continuing to serve as the vice
chancellor finance
for the university system and um it's
it's my pleasure to be with you this
morning and tom cronin
is with me tom is the university systems
government relations director good
morning
so um you were provided with some slides
and i would like to to walk you through
that
you'll see the difference in the
presentation between
interim chancellor heward and myself in
that i
have spent my career in finding it's
probably
heavier in much heavier in numbers than
than susan's presentation
um i hundred percent concur with susan's
comments she and i have been working
collaboratively
a number of months now and um i look
forward to
to continuing that even though i think
susan's probably looking forward to her
actual retirement in the not too distant
future
so um i will share my screen here if
and and walk you through um some
information about the university system
so as as susan mentioned you know the
community college system and the
university system do
have distinct missions but the one thing
we do have inc
in common is that we are a public
resource to to all granite staters
and the university system is also
focused on workforce development
in addition you know over 140 million
dollars a year
is in research is conducted here in new
hampshire
primarily at unh we also administer the
cooperative extension program across the
state
which has impact as you know in all in
all corners of new hampshire
we also have a number of programs that
provide direct community impact all
around new hampshire
i'm not going to walk through the
details on all of these slides
by all means if you have questions later
you can certainly follow up
um the covid as you know has just
turned life upside down for
everyone in the state and the university
system has really
partnered with the state on a number of
initiatives since the beginning of the
pandemic
setting up surge facilities we're doing
high capacity testing not just for our
students
but also for partnering with the
department of health and human services
the unh
lab is being used to test to test
folks in nursing homes and correctional
facilities et cetera
healthcare workforce we've got had
nursing students
come into the workforce earlier than
they might have otherwise or not for the
pandemic
we also have a vaccine distribution
center over in keene
again part of the public mission of the
university system is stepping up in
in addition to that we had to completely
pivot the way we
we provide education to our students
back in the
last to a year ago that continues we
provide
hybrid courses different
adjustments to our calendars increase
support students for
susan mentioned the impact this has had
on high schools
and it has also had significant impact
on
the learning and the support services
our students need
we have been very fortunate to receive
direct federal support
as well as support through the state
gopher office we
when we combine fiscal years 20 and 21
we estimate right now we still have
about 46 million dollars in unrecovered
costs
our costs for testing ppe
cleaning all of that over 20 and fiscal
years 20 and 21 is about 80 million
dollars
we have about 76 million dollars in
revenue losses that can be from
dorms taken offline for quarantine
summer program losses we
incurred you know when students have to
go in a hybrid model
many of them don't want to come and live
on campus if they
if they have a lot of online courses so
we have
revenue losses there as well of course
we have a lot of operational savings
when you when you
effectively shut down a campus you have
savings there you don't have the energy
bills
no one's traveling no you know we have
uh so that we have
also achieved significant operational
savings but there is a
so before the pandemic
we knew that we were coming we were in
headwinds
and the headwinds were going to get much
stronger in the coming years
this chart was published last month in
the the chronicle of higher education
and you can see in the northeast
by 2025 the number of high school
students
is going to sharply decline
and so we need to prepare for that
that's
also part of just in the last few years
just the competition that we see around
new england
for for students of the state of maine
you you have seen billboards
they are offering in-state tuition to
out-of-state students that's just an
example
so we know we have to prepare for this
big drop-off
in in the number of high school students
coming into the pipeline
you couple that with our students have
increased financial need
our students and their families have
and the pandemic has exacerbated that so
while we have
this is just through 21. enrollments
stick down a little bit
because of demographics because of
competition
the financial aid our students require
is increasing
and that puts pressure on the bottom
line
i will say that this this projection for
fiscal 21
is exclusive of one time covet impacts
we've been trying to model kind of
parsing out the recurring activity
from this one-time activity so that we
can plan for the future
and that gets me to this this modeling
we built a roadmap if you will last
spring
knowing that these headwinds we were
coming into what do we need to do
by fiscal 23 when this pandemic is
behind us
to make sure that we are on a path of
fiscal
we put a bunch of assumptions in the
modeling
demographic declines for enrollment
increased
student financial aid and a number of
other assumptions
we we also assumed flat state funding
for 22 and 23 when we built that model
flat with what the operating the the
recurring operating support if you will
from the state
based on that roadmap we need to take
70 million out of our cost structure
or about nine percent of our budget by
and we are on a path to do just that
this is
very high level this is university
system wide
the modeling shows how our revenue is
going to continue to deteriorate
and so we need to take 70 million
dollars out
to get to a place with a very small
amount in the black so what are we doing
frankly we are restructuring everything
we can get our hands on
the first thing we did on fit in for
fiscal 21 budget
everyone had to roll back to fiscal 19
actuals
we are restructuring all financial and
administrative services across the
university system we are
up to our eyeballs in that right now we
are restructuring our entire benefits
program and there are that's that's
system-wide there are also a number of
campus specific restructuring and
expense reduction
initiatives in place so we can achieve
so this shows you the um the state
operating support now i can tell you
this excludes the one time when i
when we talk about the reduction that we
that we um
have in house bill one as proposed by
the governor
this this percentage does not include
that one-time money
we received one-time money back in well
that's a typo this should say fiscal 20.
um so the governor's
proposed a four and a half million
dollar
cut in fiscal 22 from our current
eighty eight and a half million dollars
that's about a five percent reduction
now i can tell you what i admittedly i
don't know what this is going to look
like for fiscal 23
so i just took 60 like it is now
that's another reduction is the only
point there from fiscal 22 to fiscal 23.
our board uh when we when we
put our agency requests together the
flat funding at 88.5 million dollars
we committed to continue to freeze
in-state tuition
over the upcoming biennium and it's also
it was also frozen in the academic year
we're in now
excuse me our board just approved an
in-state tuition freeze last month for
the
fall and um
that again that assumed the 88.5 million
dollars
we have not had any discussions about
changing that but that's uh
that's going to have impact on us again
put more pressure as we
take that 70 million out of the cost
structure
what do we use the appropriation for
effectively tuition subsidy we buy down
the state buys down in-state tuition
we also fund services such as
cooperative extension
the agricultural experiment station and
others
and the total state appropriate the
operating
state appropriation funds about 10
percent
of the total university systems
this is a graph showing again the
continued and
increasing need on the part of our
students
so the the usnh funded direct student
aid
is continuing to increase each year
and back in 2018 you may recall
we um the university system adopted the
granite guarantee program
effectively having free tuition for
students who are
eligible by fiscal 21 you'll see we'll
have four years of that
in the you know this pipeline of
students
that's about 18.7 million dollars we
estimate
you're also aware we provide um
tuition waivers to national guard
members that's about 2.7 million dollars
last year um or 722 national guard
waivers and
effective this july 1st we have
um the tuition waiver for dependents of
disabled veterans and that will start
this summer
you can see the difference here this is
tuition and fees the difference
between an out of state and a resident
this is what we call the sticker price
when you look at the net price after
financial aid
it's pretty much stayed the same since
fiscal 16.
i would guess that by fiscal 21 that's
going to tick down a little bit
because we held tuition flat and
financial aid continues to increase
these are metrics your you you may
excuse me i've seen them in the past we
provide a dashboard
to the state treasurer's office
quarterly you can find the entire
dashboard on this link or on the state
treasurer
treasurer's website we continue to have
the
the highest graduation rate of the new
england publics
i use six year because that's what the
the federal government uses
we also have a lowest student loan
default rate what we take from that is
our students are able to graduate on
time
and gain employment to pay off their
loans
and then we also have the
lowest administrative expense per
student in relation to our
public peers around new england
there are a couple of other items in the
budget that i both house bill 1 and
house bill 2 i just want to make you
aware of
i'm going to tread very lightly on this
this topic here
the um the uh
we haven't seen the final language yet
but in house bill 2
there's a loan repayment program and i
have to tell you that
i'll speak for myself that program could
have
real impact on workforce economic and
business development in the state
um and again i'll speak for myself
that's
probably a very impactful program
the program will be funded by
redirecting about sixty percent
of the dollars in the unique program
each year and those those dollars
fund currently fund
an endowment portion to that unique
program
i i want to be clear that that endowment
can only be used the the
earnings on the endowment can only be
used for student scholarships
it's a trust document it can't be used
for anything else
the impact of of this
redirection with no other changes
in rule would be about two hundred
thousand dollars
less per year in scholarships for our
neediest new hampshire students
and that grows so it's two hundred
thousand dollars in the first year
four hundred thousand in the second year
it and
and on and on six hundred eight hundred
um we
i would also agree that there should
probably be a
a change in the way that the out that
allocation is split right now
as far as what goes into direct
scholarships and what goes into
endowment um but i'm i'm sure you're
well aware of this
uh i have not yet attended my first
commission meeting
and unique commission meeting in my uh
added role so again i'm trending lightly
on this but it is it is
an area that could impact
university students in the future the
other item
in house bill 1 excuse me
funding is zeroed out for these two
programs
that are administered through unh
their federal programs and the match has
been the federal match
well i should say the state match has
been funded by
this the state in past years
this um sbdc small
business development corp is required
that it be hosted in a college or
university
unh has proudly hosted it for 36 years
it provides about four hundred thousand
dollars a year in in-kind support
but the match this year has been wiped
out
and excuse me also there's a innovation
research center
which is a state statutory program
the state support for that has also been
zeroed out
so are we are
were we to continue the program that
will be about another 1.4 million
dollars
over the biennium that would need to be
absorbed by the university system
in addition to the reduction in our
that is going to conclude
my presentation i um
i hope to provide you some time for
questions if possible
but i want to close with
the reduction in the university systems
operating
appropriation will have impact
one at a time when we are doing
everything we can
to reduce our costs to get
back to a place after the pandemic of
fiscal sustainability
and you'll find my direct
contact as well as toms at the end of
your presentation
i would urge anyone to um
thank you very much if you hear noise in
the background someone's trying to call
me
that's one of the uh the bad things
about
zoom is that your telephone rings no
matter what and
uh it's hard to uh it's hard to prevent
that from happening
but uh thank you uh thank you very much
um we appreciate it and
um i read
you know sort of the listen to the draft
language i guess about
unique and that's obviously
something that if you don't know a lot
about it we're going to have to learn
a lot about unique the 529 program
as well as the uh as well as the two
other programs that
uh were mentioned um
uh
we need to we need to be aware of we
need to make decisions on
and um we'll see what happens so
to that point representative umberger if
if there's
in an interest um i'm sure the community
college system can as well
there are other groups in the state that
that may be able to inform you even
better than we can on those topics so
happy to connect you with those those
folks if
it would be helpful oh i'm sure it will
be
so uh we're now going to turn
is the governor going to be able to join
us
or not i believe he is still on track
for
11 30 so it might just be another minute
i'm happy to take any questions to kick
things off or if the committee wants to
take a five minute recess
uh whatever your preference is uh
chairman
okay thank you why don't we just uh kind
of
go in a holding pattern a recess and
we'll be when he shows up mickey will uh
there is that return kathy for
uh for your presentations this morning i
think that it
uh really helped us to
see the overall impact of uh both the
community college systems
and the uh university system and uh
uh i think in the in the past we have
uh or at least i have not in the past
i understand the systems but haven't
necessarily
delved into all of the things that need
to be done
and this proposal
my concept of uh of what's going on
in the in the two systems so um
i uh i really do appreciate what
uh what you've presented this afternoon
or this morning i'm sorry and okay
the governor is with us so um
oh good good morning governor um
i would like hope okay and uh i'd like
to uh
welcome you to uh division two and
to uh speak to us about your vision
of the uh combination
of the university system and the
community college system so thank you
very much and we're looking forward to
hearing from you
sure sure well i appreciate the
opportunity to come to uh to
i was gonna say come over but i guess
we're all sitting in our own locations
right now um
so i mean just not to be repetitive but
to reiterate a little bit of
of what we i talked about in the budget
address and then we can take it into
kind of another level of detail
um this is just all about evolving our
system so that so it doesn't get crushed
and i don't mean to speak in such
hyperbole but that's that's really
um ultimately nationally where a lot of
these systems uh if they do not evolve
uh meet the needs of the consumer that
being the student the parent
the new paradigm as i call it of
variables that parents and students are
looking at when they're making decisions
to enter
a higher education or to go into the
military or to get a job right out of
high school
we can't just keep pumping and it isn't
just about the dollars but you can't
just keep
pumping up the same old system decade
after decade after decade and expected
to be successful you have to evolve
with the times and and with where the
market is going um
we know that uh you know what we're
talking about today
was something that was seen maybe five
or ten years out
in terms of a real dynamic shift in
where higher education was going
uh studies three or four years ago were
showing that
up to 50 percent of mid-sized colleges
would be
closing their doors uh in the next in
the next you know i think it's a
five to ten or fifteen years um and
really what covett has done is kovat has
accelerated all of that
really right so um you know because
kovid
forced the issue of a lot of folks that
previously may not have considered
something like online education
or or folks who might have been saying
well it's got to be a four-year college
but you know what
because of cova now they're looking at
other alternatives they're looking at
other
other pathways and so all this has
really been accelerated and so what
we're really trying to do is to say
other states have done it some have been
successful some not as
successful but there are good models out
there and we're saying why is it that we
have two systems that effectively
compete against each other that offer
very different pathways
and that are very siloed so you have
effectively really uh
the seven individual locations in the
community college
the four within the university system
that's really 11 different
um systems well let's get them into one
and the benefit there isn't just about
saving dollars i got to be honest i
think we'll save some money but i don't
really care about that that's not what
this is about at all
it's really about creating a pathway
that is much more conducive for that
student
um the students of this gen z or
whatever generation is coming next i'm
not sure what we're going to call them
but this next gen z and the students of
the future are really about options are
really about smooth transitions
are really about making sure and going
into a system saying well maybe i don't
know what i want to do at 18 or 19.
maybe i had a plan on a four year
but now i want to go to two year or now
i want to get a job or whatever it is
asking that student or telling that
student well you have to get out of this
system and reapply and get into this
system over here and it's completely
different
it's com it's massively inefficient and
it just creates a better a rougher
outcome if you will a rougher pathway
for that student
as as opposed to saying look new
hampshire is one unified system you come
in
you can take a hundred different
pathways right and that's and it's
seamless and it's easy
do you know right now we have over i
think you guys may have discussed this
over 100
agreements between all the different
between nashua community college and unh
and plymouth state and
manchester for college credit transfer
and what
what transfers and what doesn't there's
literally over 100 agreements out there
it's
massively confusing on the back end and
it just
i think accentuates the fact that we
don't make it smooth for students
we make it a challenge we can say that
we have
issues with uh we allow credits to
transfer over but not always and not for
all classes
and it's still going out of one system
and into another and so this is all
about uh i call it
if you will school choice for higher
education right
um and that is where choice is most
important because that's where these
young adults are really making their
decisions about their future about their
careers about their jobs
and so it isn't just having i always
give the example of
you know a nursing student who wants to
do a research and development project at
unh
but she's a nursing student at
manchester community college why why
shouldn't we allow that to happen
in a seamless way or someone at plymouth
state that wants to that says you know
what i'm taking some great classes at
plymouth state but i want to be more
hands-on
right i want to be a business major but
i want to also i want to be in the
the construction mechanical field i want
to take welding courses to
to know what you know what that end of
my of my career path that i'm trying to
design for myself
is so it's not just business classes
here but it's business and hands-on
classes
um that again when that student
graduates with that degree and moves on
they're just so much more prepared and
as a parent
i mean i'm going to take my governor
head off as a parent i come at it from
i got a 15 year old and i got a 16 year
old so i'm
i'm going through this dynamic
questioning myself of
for my kids okay well what system is
best what system
is going to provide the most pathways
because my kids don't necessarily know
aren't going to know what they what they
want to do i didn't necessarily know
what i wanted to do at 18
and you know you kind of pick a school
or pick a pathway and you hope for the
best
i just think that we have an opportunity
to create massive efficiencies
and not ask students and parents to do
the will hope for the best
come on in with an idea of what you want
to do but even if you change your mind
even if you find something more exciting
or something more interesting or that
something that suits your skill set that
that same system is going to be there
to provide for that and so that's really
what this is about now
we didn't come in and pre-prescribe
exactly what this should look like i
i engage with the community college i
see shannon on here i engaged with
shannon
oh boy well over a year ago i think and
we batted around some ideas
i brought then brought some board
members in from both the community
college and the university system and
said look
let's start designing this let's start
planning this
and i i don't i mean they were on board
with the concept
but i i think to be honest i think they
were hesitant because they just didn't
know
if they were going to spend a lot of
time designing a system but get pushed
back here or there from their own boards
or their faculty or whatever it was
so there just wasn't an impetus to
really drive forward and say we got to
get this thing done
our pathway now is to say we're going to
take five members of the community
college five members of the university
system board put them together
we'll then see what the gaps are and by
that i mean
you know maybe some folks from one
system or another they have some
financial experience emerging and
acquisition experience but that we don't
have any legal experience on that board
because there's going to be some legal
issues with this merger
i then will bring in five more members
to with skill sets to fill in those gaps
where it needs to be not political wonks
or anything like that just
folks that know how to actually get this
done and what i've been very clear to
both boards is
you can pick who you want but this isn't
showing up for a board meeting once a
month
checking a box and having a couple
discussions i need five individuals on
both sides that want to
really dig in get their hands dirty look
at the financials the it mergers
uh the what's going on in the back end
how to make it a seamless
um uh a curriculum program uh for the
students
how to bring faculty together right um
and we've gotten a lot of very positive
feedback
obviously it's on both sides of the
aisle you know on the political spectrum
so we know it's not a political issue
we've got a lot of positive feedback
from faculty from students and parents
are
thrilled with this concept and what
we're saying is
we could study this some more we know
where that what happens with that
um or we could just get in and we can do
um
we just don't have the time right now if
you will to take five years and see how
it goes and study this and study that
the data is clear it's out there it's
been studied it's
it's all right there for us so that's
not the hard part
um actually getting the right folks in
the room and making this happen and
i've given what my idea is to give them
a kind of a one year deadline it doesn't
mean the whole system has to be done
finished design
finito in a year i don't think that's a
practical
expectation but it but we have to i
think give them
the idea to bring something back to the
legislature
give them a year to do the design bring
something back to the legislature
knowing that it's going to get tweaked
it might be a plan a or a plan b or a
plan c
we're going to hit some bumps in the
road to start but really kind of lay out
that
framework of design over the next six to
six to 12 months
and then come back to both the
legislature and the people of new
hampshire and say this is what this is
going to look like
and go if you don't do it now if you
stall
and study and wait it ain't ever going
to happen and where our two systems are
going to wither on the vine
we're not going to be competitive and
and more importantly
they're going to keep competing against
each other i mean the massive
inefficiencies
because as you go to online learning
right you you have
the community colleges doing some online
stuff you have the university doing some
online stuff
unh you have plymouth doing some they're
both they're all competing against the
private sector the snooze and whatever
of the world which
obviously have their own pathways for
individual students but everyone's
competing
against a dwindling pool as opposed to
saying we're going to
pool our resources together provide a
much better product for the student
and we're going to go and we're going to
you know market this now each individual
the 11 units if you will the 11
locations and facilities they still
maintain their their locations their
identity their brand that's very
important
nashville community college has to
maintain being nashua community college
employment state has to maintain being
plymouth state
but that's just the entry doorway to a
bigger system that broadens
folks and the vast majority of students
will still stay
you know the plymouth state students
will still likely take the most of their
classes and on options
at plymouth state same with unh and
otherwise but
to have that option right that that
smooth revolving
door from one location to another where
you're not reapplying and you're not
going
through hoops it's a seamless transition
where you're just taking another class
or you're working with professors from
another location the whole
system is open to you as a student i
think that's an incredibly exciting
thing
to be offering and i don't i got to be
honest i don't think it's nearly as hard
as people think it is i really don't
um you you have much larger entities
merging all the time in the united
states they might be private entities
and whatnot
but you have much larger m a uh
acquisitions and going on and much
much heavier heads butting together as
opposed to
two public systems that know where they
are they don't have to redesign they
don't have to necessarily rebrand
they just need to kind of put the back
ends together and create a seamless
front end for the students
it's it's not a huge leap i know a lot
of folks like to think well this is
going to take
a decade to complete now it's not going
to take no no any merger and acquisition
that takes more than two and a half to
three years to complete
was never designed right in the first
place so we know this can be done and
and again it doesn't mean that we have
to give ourselves an end date of one
year and then we're
it's done or it's not but really putting
i think that framework together allowing
the boards and those that are on the
front lines of this to have a lot of the
input in that as opposed to
the governor and the legislature
pre-determining and dictating it
um the date is there and so again i
think the time is right
um uh unfortunately what the data says
is if we don't move now
um we're just going to get further and
further down the road we're also at a
crossroads of opportunity
neither of them have chancellors right
now even i think jeremy
the the the head of the board over at
community colleges is now
has indicated that he's going to be
moving on so you don't want to bring in
chancellors to two systems knowing that
you're going to merge the systems
whether it's a year or three years down
the line um
and then maybe have to go find another
chancellor that works better with this
new newly designed system the
opportunity
all the stars are kind of lining up to
get this done now
to look at where the system is going to
go you know bring them together
um and then you find an individual or a
team of individuals
that have the right skill sets for that
newly designed system
right don't bring somebody in um
i mean bringing somebody in to be a
chancellor system is hard enough there's
already a transition there
you'll be in endless transition i guess
is my point uh if you bring them in
and then immediately charge you with the
task of bringing everything together
that that's that's too much to ask of
any individual and it's not fair to them
or or the systems
or or the process that you're trying to
set up so so the timing is just really
really
really good everything is lining up it's
a i think it's a bipartisan positive
effort
my only fear is that we slow down
frankly um i don't i think you can push
it i think we haven't
if i didn't have faith in the
individuals on the board and the
individuals that are
that are managing the community college
the individuals that are managing the
university we have awesome
awesome teams there right now really
good teams if i didn't have faith in
those individuals i wouldn't be making
this
this this push um but we just have the
right
teams at the right time in the right
moment to make this thing happen
um and that's it i mean that's that's
kind of where i am i could go on all day
as you guys know
but um but again i think allowing for
that flexibility and not predetermining
everything is
is actually a real asset to us in
allowing those boards to come together
we fill it in with skill sets
real skill sets uh that would be
required in in such an endeavor
i think the next year could be really
exciting and then we can launch
something
at least the preliminary first phases of
it within a year or two i i think you
just got to get started now and
you know the stars are aligning let's uh
let's seize the opportunity when it's
presented to us
uh governor would you mind taking a
couple of questions
sure
okay so folks uh
representative weiler i see that you
have your hand up
thank you madam chair um right now our
task is to try to
complete a budget and we don't have any
forecast
that's going to help us whether this is
going to be a change is it going to be
more money less money and so on and so
forth
and the other thing i fear is that
normally
division two has a history of being more
generous to the community college
than to the unh we provide a higher
percentage of the
um budget to the community college
because we think it helps more people
in new hampshire and especially more
people that are starting out
and can't afford a four-year college so
we want to encourage them by giving more
money to the community college than we
do to the unh
because they have far more accessibility
to funds and
and so on and so forth and out-of-state
tuition that helps them a little
and uh so here's here's the quandary i
see immediately
um if we gave a batch of money to this
combined thing is unh going to take the
biggest share
or are we still going to be feeling that
community college hasn't been
left and by by the way we did it before
we made sure that we were helping the
community college and the students the
most needed
by giving a little more money to the
community college and the unh
since they had had more uh accessibility
to funds and so on and contracts etc
that they wouldn't need as much so we
were giving like i think
20 some percent of the budget to the
community college and about eight
percent
i see kathy prevention she'd know it to
the decimal point
uh what we were giving to unh and uh
so my fear is how's the money going to
go to this
combined sure so let me address that so
in my budget i propose basically level
funding the university system in the
first year
right and the community college both of
them because they're both going to
continue
in this next year exactly as is
operations have to continue
exactly as is nothing is fundamentally
changing um that's when the work is
really being done
you're also bringing in a single you
know at some point hopefully within the
next year you're
you you're defining what this framework
of this new entity
looks like uh you're bringing in and
looking for a chancellor to handle that
entity
and then in my second year of the budget
we look at combining that together now
again you could keep it separate for at
least the next year
possibly you know for the second year
but i think the opportunity is to bring
everything together
have the individual chancellor the
individual system where you're funding
it
and then it's it's not it's not unh
versus national community
college anymore it's one singular system
with a chancellor that has
the op the opportunity to make sure all
11 parts are moving
right now the left hand and the right
hand are really working synergistically
the other thing i would caution is i i
have heard some talk of
well just as you brought up ken well
back you know back in the day and you're
absolutely right the community college
always gets a little more favorable
treatment on on the financial side
there's a lot of talk of yesterday you
got them i think everyone has to move on
from that
you know i heard people telling me about
when i discussed this
concept you know talking to me about
well mark huddleston
mark huddleston that guy's been gone for
years
i don't care about mark carlston i don't
care about anyone that is not of today
because it's all about tomorrow right
and so i just what i think the
opportunity is to finally get away from
the one system versus another that's
exactly what you brought up
we should never have one system
competing against another when they're
both public system you have one system
a single chancellor and his team working
with the the individual presidents and
managers of those
of of the 11 units if you will i don't
know what we want to call them
um and saying okay based on the need and
the demand here's here's
how the money and how you manage it out
almost like a business you you really
need a ceo
more than a chancellor right you need to
see this as
11 divisions if you will of the same
company all providing kind of a
different entryway maybe a different uh
different specialties
but it's really all of the same business
the same company trying to provide
the same opportunity which is the
product that's your product right that
opportunity for the students
so i see as synergizing the systems not
only are you
you're undoubtedly going to save money
right because you just you don't need
two i.t systems you don't i mean we
if you added up all the back end systems
that we have
duplicated um it's just in its time it
served a purpose but at this point and
going forward i think it's archaic
and i don't think we should be
supporting that that kind of
inefficiency
so you can create massive efficiencies
there and it's a one system where you're
not competing one against the other
anymore
um obviously unh is the big dog always
has been right and likely it's going to
be for quite some time and that provides
a huge opportunity for our system
but it's not the big dog over everyone
else no way
it is 11 on par and you need to bring in
a team and a chancellor
that really understand and appreciate
that and so what we're doing is
i mean let's face it the the
inappropriate stigma that is out there
is that a community college is somehow
second tier it's not
that the faculty and the students are
second tier they're not
they are not and that's what we're
trying to get away from this whole idea
that
the community college is somehow second
tier to the no way it's one of the best
community college systems in the country
it's run so well and creates all this
amazing opportunity
it is not second tier it's right on par
and so that's why i get excited about
bringing everyone on to an even level
under one roof that will be treated as
equals
thank you uh representative bucco you
have a quick question
yes thank you madam chair and thank you
governor
um so one of the advantages of uh of of
the community college is the resilience
and the
ability to adapt and in fact in their
presentation there today they have
three pages of um partnerships with
employers
and so my concern is will will they
become
will they become one big will be still
be able to
adapt when it when if or will they
become just too big
when they merge no i think that i think
that's one of the awesome opportunities
if you look at
the relationships community colleges
have with employers and the
relationships that the university system
has
with different employers um there's some
crossover there but it tends to be a
little bit different
but again it's all about the students
path
right let's say unh has a great
partnership with lonza over at pease
which is you know the
pharmaceutical manufacturer and all that
sort of thing unh is
designing this giant bio life sciences
opportunity and building they're
doubling their
number of nursing and all of that so
they are going to naturally have their
group of businesses and not just on a
local level but on a national level that
they're interacting with doing research
with and developing with
and so why should the opportunity is now
that community that the manchester
community college student
has all that same access right and vice
versa the students at unh
that maybe aren't into the research and
development side but want a little more
of a local connection to some of to some
of the more mid-sized
um more main street real businesses
manufacturing whatever it might be
because the community colleges tend to
have much better
connections to the manufacturing world
and as manufacturing from overseas is
coming back into the us and will
continue to do so
over the next few years there's going to
be huge opportunities there
and as we all know you know
manufacturing again was
kind of had this stigma a few years ago
and we're really changing that paradigm
so now those students are going to be
able to
work through the community college's
contacts all that all the individual
entities those 11 entities still
maintain
their identities their brand their
relationships but we're just opening
those
uh contacts which traditionally are
separated now to everybody
right you're you're if you are a post
you know you're a higher education
student in new hampshire
you get the golden ticket to everything
we're not siloing you
with that market segment or those you
know those businesses
um we're letting everybody kind of play
and i just think that's a rising tide
floats all boats
thank you thank you uh representative
whoops thank you governor for taking my
question thank you madam chair
um i agree that the
number of high school students are
reducing drastically across our state
but at the same time we're seeing those
reductions
we're seeing um a huge increase
in the number of young adults of
middle age people that are seeking
education in different ways um just
i've worked at snoop during the time
they had their big explosion
um in terms of their online program and
so we're seeing
different populations of people coming
in
my big concern is that when you create
a huge system that needs
many many different products it gets
harder
for individuals to manipulate the system
or to
get into the system and i just fear that
the special
unh for example has its own unique um
you know if i'm a high school student
i'm getting ready i want to go to unh
that that's where i want to go because i
want a campus i want to play sports i
want to do all these things
but you know if i'm 35 years old and
i've got two kids
um i'm trying to get my um degree my
graduate degree
i'm only looking for those courses and i
want to be able to do it if i can online
that would be great
um how do i do that effectively so i'm
just concerned
about creating a system that's so huge
that all of a sudden we won't have that
nimbleness that we see in the community
college and we won't have that
sophistication
that we see from the university system
if you could respond please
sure i mean i'll give you a quick
example i can give you is
you know a few years ago this state
could even didn't even provide an lpn
program for nurses
you could have an lna program here you
could have the or go to the university
and get
your rn or go you know or you could even
go i think manchester community college
had the rn program over there
so you had all these different programs
but we weren't even providing
one of the most important certifications
that you can get as a nurse
and i remember sitting down with a young
woman she was getting her
through the governor's scholarship
program i created she was she was
getting her nursing degree at the red
cross
and it was an l and she was a single mom
and she said yeah this was great you
know the
to your point it was very nimble i could
come in i got my l
my my lna and i said well that's great
what do you want to do she said well
i i'd like to become an rn but i can't
do it
right i can't do it because you gotta
that's more of a longer time commitment
i'm a single mom
i don't have we don't have those
programs here i said what about an lpn
and then we looked into it we quickly
realized there was no lpn program
the community colleges had gotten rid of
it they had refused
they didn't want to be nimble right they
wanted a system
that stayed in their lane right so i had
to force the com
a couple of the community colleges to
pick up that lpn program and thank god i
did because lpns
are what you find in long-term care
facilities is it's just a whole nother
level of nursing and opportunity and we
weren't creating that bridge
so yes the individual systems it's true
a lot of smaller systems can be
are obviously going to be can you can
make the argument they can be more
nimble
but they can also be much more limited
in what they're offering
because you know for for various reasons
for economic reasons or whatever
but now opening that door up i'm just
using the one example of nursing
you're providing a whole different
pathway for that individual that wants
to just take the night classes
and get an lpn or wants to just take
night classes but still be able to get
her rn
because she's part of a system that has
an rn degree program
but she can do it with the nimbleness of
the community college now
right so the it isn't i i don't i
i think we we shouldn't be looking at
this as look at what we're going to lose
i think you look at the the bridges that
we're gaining
and those are bridges that create better
career pathways for these students
i think you could take that to a i'm
going to go back to the example i also
gave of
somebody who who's uh wants to get in or
get their business degree
but now they want their business degree
um they're in the four-year college but
you know what they want to be in
construction they want to be in
manufacturing there's huge opportunities
there
but you know what they want to they want
to also understand what's happening on
the manufacturing floor
right how is that car being put together
how is that this big piece of digital
equipment being put together
well now the four-year university system
doesn't offer those but now they can
take that
so instead of just entering the
workforce with their you know their
mba or whatever it is and they're you
know the the peter paul school is
wonderful for business degrees and all
that
now we're merging that the peter the the
academics of the peter paul school with
the real world
that the community college that's
nimbleness that didn't exist
in the university system previously so
we're not taking anything away from the
community college system we're just
adding
their asset into that base so of course
with any m
a merger you're gonna have you can you
can look at where it's gonna
well this might not work here and that
might not work there but if you look at
strictly from the students point of view
we're not taking any nimbleness away
from the community college system
look there's still seven community
colleges that are part of one larger
system
right now they're going to be those
seven are now part of a system of
kind of a former system of 11 right with
a single point
and a single marketing a single brand
you know that that i think that that's
an opportunity
or i should say a marketing and a brand
that kind of lies over those individuals
so they're still going to nashville
in the nashua i don't know whether you
are called national community college i
don't know name it whatever you want
they're still going through that door
but that door once you get through that
door it's a much bigger
bigger system behind it and and they get
to build on the opportunities for their
okay i have to i uh no
mary let we need okay um i have two more
questions
uh one from representative petrie and
one from representative lin
uh if that's okay governor will true
okay thank you representative petra you
have a question
yeah thank you madam chair thank you
governor for taking the question
uh when i first heard this proposal i
was worried about uh
losing the advantage of the
affordability of the community colleges
i mean it's that's probably the
community calls are the best kept
secrets
of of this state i mean they and and you
can transition on to the uh
university system and uh i heard those
comments again this morning could you
and i heard you commented you didn't
really care about the cost
but the affordability makes that a
very viable situation sure
i think the way we charge for higher
education is
also archaic we're doing it the same way
we've always done it
no one has ever challenged the system to
say let's just take the university
system and then we'll do the community
college
well every credit cost x it's thirteen
thousand four hundred 472 dollars to go
to the university system of new
hampshire
right and that's it and then you go in
and you take your courses and you do
your thing
and the community college on average is
seven thousand dollars per year
i think there's an opportunity here to
basically blow that up
and say let's design i'm this is just me
thinking that i'm no expert
but let's design a menu let's design a i
mean not a menu of
not everything a la carte of course but
a menu that says look
there's uh there's a b there's pathway a
b
c and d and a is is you know the
cheapest and d
is kind of the gold-plated version the
most expensive the most immersive
with academics and opportunity um but
there's some folks that want to
go kind of open door b and that has a
certain number of classes here and a
certain amount of
of hands on there and a certain amount
of research and development there and
opportunity there
i just think there's a huge opportunity
to re-examine how we charge for
for this all this stuff in the first
place the community college is an
amazing kept secret
but also remember it's the second most
expensive community college in the
country
i think we can go cheaper i think you do
that by providing
more and better options more enticing
options there could be pathways that are
more
expensive there could be pathways that
are cheaper but
i mean it's it's it's it's expensive
next to vermont i think vermont's number
one and
and community in new hampshire is number
two in terms of cost i just think
there's an opportunity by doing this
to allow to to get a little more
creative about what we're offering
and it isn't just community college will
cost you x university system will cost
you why
that's a two year this is a four year
pick your door good luck
hope you picked right that's exactly
what we're trying to get away from
i think by offering more options you
have the opportunity to
just provide more flexibility in that
pricing and and again it's it maybe it's
not
as immersive of a program maybe it's
it's more for
you know single moms that have to you
know be at home with the kids a little
bit but still want to advance their
career or
or upskilling opportunities those can be
a little bit cheaper
but not and look maybe maybe at the end
of the day you still just go by the
course at the end of the day we can't
figure it out
and look we're still going to say if you
want this pathway with these courses
you're not necessarily losing the cost
there or the cost opportunities for
those individuals i just think by
putting it all together
it gives you the the ability to be more
to explore the idea
look i think even if you don't put them
together i think both these systems have
to get aggressive about understanding
how they're what they're charging and
what their what what the product is
people have to get the value of the
product there's a very good
value in the community college don't get
me wrong but i just think you can do
better
and and no one's ever challenged that
everyone is just sticking in their lane
we'll go to the legislature we'll beg
for money we'll compete against the
university
we'll get what we can we'll adjust our
cost variables accordingly
we'll do our our faculty contracts
accordingly and we'll hope that the
students keep coming in
and and we pray that next year is almost
as good as it was this year
and hopefully hopefully it'll keep
working it's not going to keep working
right because when you're charging 7 000
for the community college it's a great
product
but you're not charging seven the snooze
of the world aren't charging seven
thousand for online learning
and so that's going to force everyone to
do more on the online learning side and
pretty soon both systems are going to
be competing each other for that that
lower cost
product the lower cost product doesn't
just need to be online
right it can be a more hands-on more
immersive more traditional
uh product but you do that by i think by
kind of expanding
the opportunities and kind of
whiteboarding this thing you know
tearing it right down and saying look
here's our costs here's where we need to
be here's the opportunities we can
provide and here's the different tiers
that that we could immerse within both
systems
thank you uh representative lynn
uh thank you governor for taking my
question i i guess i should
stay at the outset i i really do think
that this is an excellent
idea i mean i i think that there will be
at least there should be some cause some
significant cost savings in addition to
all the other
things that you pointed out but i i
guess my question is this
um i i as i understand it the idea would
be to appoint this
i guess 15 person board that would sort
of work out
the details and that you know that i'm
sure that there are a lot of details to
be worked out and that makes sense
the one thing i'm wondering is this
if you know if if you're committed to
doing this and
and i'm glad that you are and they'll
and you know assuming that the
legislature also
signs on to do this um then i wonder if
it wouldn't make sense
to appoint a a chancellor
you know now or where i say now i mean
very soon
before the before the one-year period
goes by
because i guess i'm i'm really sort of
concerned that
and i don't mean to suggest anybody i'm
sure everybody will operate in good
faith and work
you know very hard to to bring this
about
but i'm i'm sort of wondering if if it
doesn't make sense to have somebody
that's kind of
in charge from the beginning that can
say
you know that can sort of crack the whip
if
if it seems like things are you know
people are trying to find reasons to
sort of not make it happen so that
that's my really only only question
would it make sense to appoint
somebody sooner rather than later yes no
i think
your spot on uh representative lin um
once i think once we make the
commitments the board you know the
legislature is on board i guess what uh
what i was saying i i i wasn't very
clear i don't want them to appoint
anyone now before we've decided whether
we're go or no
right but you're absolutely right you
need someone kind of leading the charge
not just running the meetings but really
keeping the train on the track
it's a giant train the track can go in a
lot of ways
it's going to be a lot of work to manage
this and keep this on board i think
you're probably bringing folks from both
of the community college
you know the operations side and the
university side as well to support
an individual maybe you bring in the
individual as the new
the new the new ceo chancellor whatever
you want to call it maybe bringing
someone in to say look
you're our two two to three year guy or
girl or woman
and and you're the individual that's
going to drive this thing and then we'll
decide you know you give them like a
temporary
a shorter term contract to really put
this thing together
and maybe they're the answer to manage
it in the long term maybe they're not
maybe you want to bring someone else in
but no
i think you're spot on as soon as i
think that once we can if we can make
this commitment
and and i'll say we're going to give it
our 110 best effort
you're right you need a manage someone
on the managing side
uh really driving forward on this i
someone asked me who that would be i
don't know
i mean i i can tell you what skill sets
i think that person needs but i
can tell you i have nobody in mind i
have uh no no pre
predilections on any of that i'm just
trying to make sure we're staying
focused on
can we you know does this make sense and
and by the way
look i'm not saying what i'm proposing
you know is
is the end-all be-all only answer um i
think it's the
i think what we've really tried to do is
provide the best option we have to
maintain flexibility
to let the the boards really design the
system i didn't want to come in
and pre-determine much of that but i
think you're absolutely right i think
you do need someone at the helm very
early on
to keep this process on track to meet
the goals and the deadlines that will
have to be there
if you want to if you want to be
successful thank you very much
thank you governor we
so appreciate you spending this last
however long with us and uh and i hope
that
uh in some ways that uh
you have cleared up some of the
questions that
uh that our folks have and um
we will uh we'll be working through this
somehow
and uh and i really uh i really thank
you
for joining us today you bet well look i
i just if i may madam chairwoman i i
can't thank you guys enough
um i don't do a whole lot of interaction
uh with the committees
uh because i kind of for the budget
stuff i usually let the legislature have
to make those decisions
uh but on this one i think um it is it
is a leap
it is not a leap of faith but it is a
leap to say
we're gonna get this thing done and i
just i want i i hope folks take it with
the
excitement and opportunity that i see it
as um
it's easy to say no everybody can say no
right
but i think there is a whole lot of
opportunity um
and and to have kind of that bipartisan
support all hands on deck
um it'll be a challenge but i just let's
let's have some fun
like let's just whiteboard this thing
out and see what we can do and
and i and i really mean it i know folks
get sick and tired of me saying we're
the gold standard
we kind of are we're the pace setters
for the rest of the country
in so many areas of what we go after
whether it's what we're doing with drugs
what we're doing
with mental health the opportunities
we're trying to create in the business
community
and now taking our our our higher
education and saying
look snoo made a leap of huge faith if
you will
a decade ago 15 years ago and they said
we're going to go really all in
on the online stuff before anybody else
and they knocked it out of the park they
owned the market
on it right um everyone else who was
kind of left behind is scrambling
let's leave the pack let's lead the pack
in the new design for higher education
so i appreciate the time and i
appreciate everyone at least giving it
you know it's full consideration
thank you so much thanks guys we'll see
you
uh committee we will be
um getting back together i've got
uh about five after twelve
oh it's ten after twelve so let's make
it
um 20 minutes to one
that'll give you an opportunity to uh
have something to eat anyhow so we'll uh
we'll see about 20 minutes to one
thank you hey um madame here
yes all right uh next wednesday uh
when he how long do you plan to go for
that
meeting
okay mickey what's next wednesday i
think we have the department of
education starting at 10 o'clock
ah yes i've we've changed that we've
changed the meetings
that week the next week about what four
times
so um we will probably go at least the
two hours and probably into the
afternoon as well joe okay because my
wife has an
uh an operation uh she has to go to on
uh at one o'clock in portsmouth so
i'll probably be here for the first two
hours and then i have to leave
okay that's certainly no problem i mean
we all have
we all have commitments and uh and i
understand that so
i hate to miss i hate the mess thanks i
i got that but sometimes it happens so
all right we'll see you back at 20
minutes to one